remember a few years ago when Jeffrey
Epstein allegedly killed himself in a
Manhattan jail cell and how we never
learned a single thing more about a
single person involved in his
International sex trafficking ring that
included many of the most famous and
powerful people on Earth well according
to Senate Judiciary Committee chairman
dick Durban the reason we never learned
anything more is because no one cares
chairman deran can I ask you a quick
question um why won't you subpoena
Jeffrey Epstein's flight logs so who are
you Hillary vaugh with Fox with Fox of
course uh I don't know anything about
his flight logs but why won't you
subpoena them why don't you want to know
I don't even know the issue I know who
epine was but I certainly don't know
anything about the issue well he was
charged with sex trafficking so why
don't you want to know who was utilizing
his private plane never been raised by
anyone Senator Blackburn has wanted to
subpoena them and there hasn't been a
vote in your committee said a word to me
not a word but aren't you curious like
what high-profile or powerful people
might be closeted predators and
pedophiles doesn't that concern you of
course so why won't you subpoena them if
you can it's the first time anyone has
raised it thank you fox so do you are
you curious about it will you do
it why haven't we seen the flight log no
one's ever asked for it that's the first
time ever hearing of it who no one has
even raised the topic except if of
course for lots of people as Republican
senator marshia Blackburn quickly
reminded him I understand you made some
statements about the Jeffrey Epstein
flight logs I had not spoken to you one
time about this issue since we're in the
business of issuing subpoenas now here
are a few more that I filed a subpoena
to Jeffrey Epstein's estate to provide
the flight logs for his private plane
given the numerous allegations of human
trafficking and a sexual abuse
surrounding Mr
Epstein now I bet there are some more
examples even that one pretty
devastating and I think dick Durban is
right in a way there are a lot of people
who do not want to see the Epstein
flight log namely the people who are on
it and I'm not even accusing tricky dick
Durban of having flown on the Lolita
Express I have no reason to think that
he did
but we know for a fact that some of his
friends did most people think DC Elites
are stonewalling the release of the
Epstein flight log because they're on it
and perhaps in some cases that's part of
their
reluctance I think the bigger reason
though for the delay is that the Epstein
sex ring was obviously a massive
intelligence operation first of all all
of his properties had cameras all over
the place including in the rooms where
the weird stuff went on the guy had logs
and logs of this kind of material
Epstein's Madam his business partner who
procured the girls is the daughter of
Robert Maxwell a known spy for Mad six
serving and former leaders of which
attended his funeral and it wasn't just
Israel that Robert Maxwell spied for the
British foreign office suspected him of
working for the KGB and of being a
double or even a triple agent a
Justified suspicion since Maxwell also
spied for British intelligence MI6 but
forget about Robert Maxwell for a second
we also have on good authority that
Jeffrey Epstein himself was connected to
American intelligence Alex aosta
president Trump's labor secretary
famously reportedly testified that when
he was us attorney Prosecuting Jeffrey
Epstein the first time he was told to
lay off because Epstein quote belonged
to
intelligence the fact that prominent
Americans were Epstein's customers is
scandalous enough but that is nothing
compared paired with the fact that
political Elites seem to have been
involved on the business side of things
too I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show this
episode's brought to you by good
ranchers head on over to
goodranchers.com subscribe today with
code nolles kwes to claim your free
Limited stock Christmas ham before it
sells
out daily wires daily wires daily shows
Fillin host the guy who took over from
Trevor Noah who took over from John
Stewart has just made some Waves by
begging Joe Biden not to run for
president again we will get to that in
just a moment first though speaking of
deep State
spying Christopher Ray the director of
the FBI was just asked by Republican
senator Josh Holly to give some account
of what we now know to be a a pretty
Broad and
significant operation of the FBI to spy
on Catholics this came out because there
was a leaked memo that showed that the
Biden doj and FBI were spying on
traditional Catholic parishes and
initially the FBI denied this and said
no no it was a mistake we had no idea
we're disgusted it was a oneoff it's
been taken out of the FBI database but
then it turns out there were other field
offices involved as well this was
obviously a broad operation so Holly
asks Christopher Ray about this here's
Ray's
non-answer how many other parishes
around the country have priests or choir
directors been approached by the way are
are Catholic choirs now are they are
they breeding grounds for domestic
terrorism is this is this your latest
Theory how many other parishes have FBI
agents approached priest and inquire
directors to ask about parishioners look
Senator we do not and will not conduct
investigations based on anybody's
exercise of their constitutionally you
have done so and your memo explicitly
asks for it your memo labels traditional
Catholics as racially and ethnically
motivated violent extremists in need of
Investigation you have a list of
churches a list in the memo you've
repeatedly said we don't Target churches
we don't list churches there listed in
the memo so how many other parishes have
you gone to to talk to choir directors
For Heaven's Sake as I've you know the
answer to that
question no I don't know the answer to
that
question no I no I don't the the
original answer he knew was no we've
never done this it's never happened how
dare you suggest Senator H that we would
ever do this paully says it's in your
own
words how we you think we would Target
parishes I have the list of the parishes
you were targeting oh oh you got that
you got that memo huh yeah okay uh I
don't know plead the fifth beats
me obviously it was extensive this
operation and Senator Holly here is
doing an excellent job in his grilling
of Ray of expressing the outrage that a
lot of Americans feel and I am outraged
but I'm not surprised in the
least of course Americans of course of
of course the American regime is going
to protect liberalism liberalism is the
the dominating Force now in recent
Decades of the American regime and of
course Liberals are going to view
Christians as enemies of that regime
rightly so the two don't really go
together all that
well liberalism certainly certainly
traditional Christianity or conservative
Christianity or whatever modifiers the
these Libs want to throw on to the faith
that has animated our whole civilization
certainly that is opposed to
liberalism and as as our Lord reminds us
a man cannot serve two masters so in as
much as liberalism and Christianity
conflict in as much as they make
different claims about the good and the
true and the beautiful and how we ought
to behave and what Society ought to look
like in as much as they disagree and
they disagree pretty significantly
compare oh I don't know
uh the Streets of San Francisco today
and the laws that govern the Streets of
San Francisco with say the laws of
Christendom at its height they're pretty
different well in as much as they
conflict the political establishment is
going to pick liberalism and it's going
to view Christianity as the enemy
rightly so Christianity is an enemy of
modern decadent degenerate liberalism
it's just a fact now people in Hollywood
are trying to explore this this theme as
well Rob Riner who Meathead you know
know from All in the Family uh Riner is
making a documentary on Christian
nationalism and Riner is an atheist and
he's a big lib and there's no doubt
about that he has said nice things about
Christianity in the past In fairness he
said that he's not a Christian but he
tries to live like a Christian he said
that you know love your neighbor as
yourself is as good a a maxim as he's
ever heard so he's attracted
to some kind of uh
single aspect of Christianity but he
doesn't even though he's attracted to
that it's an important rule he he does
not he's not sufficiently attracted to
embrace the whole faith in fact he seems
fairly opposed to the faith uh and he's
certainly opposed to the faith in
forming American politics and that
wouldn't be a big story libs are going
to make anti-christian movies they do it
all the time the bigger part of the
story is that
major Evangelical
leaders major christian leaders at some
point or another
have actually joined Rob Riner in
attacking Christian nationalism we'll
get to that in one second first though
we obviously primarily want to store up
our Treasures in Heaven but when you
want to supply your own material needs
on Earth for the duration of your life
you you'll probably want some resources
for that which is why you got to check
out Birch gold right now text nolles to
98 9898 diversify your savings with
physical precious medals while
stockpiling silver in your home safe
take advantage of Birch gold group's
most popular special of the year now
through December 22nd for every $5,000
you spend with Birch gold they will send
you a 1o silver eagle coin for free
that's a pretty good deal text Nolls
kwes to 98 9898 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
and silver and have it shipped directly
to your home or have Birch Gold's
precious metal Specialists help you
convert an existing Ira or 401K into a
tax sheltered IRA and gold for no money
out of pocket they will send you free
silver for every $5,000 you purchase
keep it for for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year just text the keyword
nolles kwes 298 9898 to claim your
eligibility with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold Tex NES kwes to
9898 98 claim your eligibility for free
silver un qualifying purchases before
December 22nd that is nolles kwes to
9898 98 Rob Riner going after Christian
nationalism America and Christianity are
like baseball and apple pie and we
celebrate them
together I was 16 17 years old when I
became a Christian I'm an Evangelical
Minister I've been a Christian my whole
life I'm a Christian nationalist I have
nothing to be ashamed of because that's
what most Americans are is Christian
nationalism
Christian um no it
isn't we should should be blazing forth
as a countercultural example and instead
we're leading the charge of malice and
division Christian nationalism uses
Christianity as a means to an end that
end being some form of
authoritarianism being a Christian is
about the values of inclusion Christian
nationalism is certainly not based on
the values of the Gospel this is not a
movement about Christian values this is
about Christian
power okay I don't recognize anyone in
this movie other than David French who
is exactly the sort of person I would
expect to be in this movie David French
a former writer for National Review a
Libertarian or neoconservative minded uh
right-winger but he wrote for he wrote
for conservative Publications and he was
a member of conservative organizations
and then Trump I guess radicalized him
and now he's pretty clearly on the left
he was writing for the Atlantic for a
while now I think he's writing for the
New York Times and his raise on debt
appears to be to attack from the from
the authority of an American Evangelical
a a conservative but not that kind of
conservative you know a court gester in
the Kingdom of liberalism from his his
uh self-styled identity as a
Conservative Christian he attacks
conservatives and he attacks Christians
now the reason I don't know any of the
other people in here and the only reason
I know David French is because he ran in
conservative circles for some time is
is it this is all Protestants who are in
this movie there are no Catholics and
it's no knock on Protestants certainly
no knock on evangelicals many of my best
friends are evangelicals and Protestants
but I'm I'm not I'm a Catholic and so
I'm just not as familiar with these
leaders of the Evangelical movement
so why is that why is it that it's
evangelicals in this movie well it it's
no knock on evangelicals exactly it's
it's more to do with Christian
nationalism Christian nationalism is a
fundamentally Protestant
movement now in practice I support
Christian nationalism I and in practice
I guess David French and those those
evangelicals in this movie oppose
Christian nationalism the reason that I
support Christian nationalism
practically is because we have a nation
I respect our nation I'm a patriot love
my country it's an extension of filial
piety and the soul of our nation is
Christian it was
founded explicitly as a Christian Nation
in 1620 by the pilgrims at Plymouth Rock
who sailed here on the Mayflower which
is the name of an excellent brand of
cigars and the uh leaders of the
Massachusetts Bay Colony called this a a
model of Christian charity a shining
city on a hill our founding fathers
spoke in broadly Christian terms John
Adams said that our Morality In America
would have to be a Christian morality
John J said exactly the same thing
George Washington gave thanks to God
Abraham Lincoln uh never wrote or spoke
without in some way channeling the King
James Bible we've got in God we trust on
our money it's a Christian country most
people are Christian it's just a
Christian country there's no other way
to put it so if we're a nation and we're
going to be Christian well then I guess
that's Christian nationalism right but
the Liberals don't like that because the
Liberals don't like Christianity and
they don't like nation states what they
want is liberal globalism now the reason
I say Christian nationalism is
fundamentally Protestant is because
nationalism is fundamentally Protestant
nationalism is a
of the West failan system the Treaty of
Augsburg and the piece of West philia
which put an end to the religious wars
which came about as a result of the
cracking up of the unity of Christendom
so before all of that
happened Europe Christendom broadly was
United in one Faith with lots of
different political entities but there
was a connection between the unified
faith and all of the different political
entities notably the Holy Roman Empire
but even other little political entities
and
therefore the civilization had a Unity
we all had the same faith and and that
Faith was expressed visibly in political
life because our faith is an
incarnational Faith because our Lord is
Incarnate he's not just floating in the
sky he enters into history in time and
space he picks specific Apostles he
gives them the keys to the kingdom of
heaven he says go forth and Make
Disciples of all Nations he says go feed
my sheep he says on this rock I will
build my church Simon Peter you're now
Peter which means
he says these things and then there's a
visible expression and the apostles go
off to all the corners of the World and
St Thomas makes it all the way to India
and Peter and Paul go to Rome and it
it's a you what separates Christianity
from other religious Traditions is
that you can trace it through journalism
you can you can trace it not just
through philosophy or abstract theology
but with real people in real time and
space there's a there's an an Apostolic
succession going all the way back to our
Lord which means
that if you are
Christian you must believe that the
faith has some kind of physical
expression and a community expression
unfortunately though certain branches of
branches of sects of branches of modern
Christianity have ignored all of that
and they want to just abstract
everything about the faith and they want
to make Rel something that you just do
in your own little head maybe quietly at
night in your room but that has no
visible expression anywhere but we can't
do that Christianity spreads as a
community and we because we're social
creatures because we're the political
animal even the variability to pray will
expand or diminish based on political
circumstances do we live in a culture
that's conducive to prayer that's
conducive to the flourishing of the
religion or not don't forget
Christianity is not a it's not a
polytheistic religion okay our God is a
jealous God and we'll have no other gods
before
him so when you have people here saying
look I'm a Christian oh I'm a Christian
I love Christianity and everything but
Christian
nationalism is
not it's not Christian at all it's
opposed to Christianity it's
authoritarian what does that mean author
it certainly makes demands of you it
certainly gives a shape to public life I
don't what I wouldn't call that
authoritarian but yeah it's it's not
liberal I guess yeah that's true it's
about power yeah well there yeah there
is I mean we think that Jesus Christ is
King of the universe yeah there's power
there yes there's Authority what you
bind on Earth will be bound in heaven
what you lose on Earth will be Loos in
heaven that implies Authority yeah but
it's not liberal you're well there it is
you've hit the nail on the head and so
this is the question for the people in
Rob Reiner's movie This is the question
for David
French are you first a Christian or are
you first a
liberal which is it many are going to
want to say well I'm both oh okay you
can serve two Gods you can to serve two
masters you got to pick one which you
got which is it and there are many
people look I I don't mean to only
single out the Evangelical Protestants
there are many Catholics who think in
this way too though it's not a
traditionally Catholic way of thinking
which means that the FBI is not going to
investigate this way of thinking but
but these these ideas in as much as they
conflict are going to require that we
choose one or the other which is it
which is it folks are we in a Christian
Nation or are we in a liberal globalist
hodgepodge of just vague nothingness for
me if I got to pick one just a practical
reality I'll choose the
former now speaking of the Soul you know
they say the eyes are the window to the
soul and they say the windows are the
eyes to your home which is why you got
to check out Renewal by Anderson right
now text nolles to 200 300 for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they want to do but rather
something they have to do have you put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive then I've got
great news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free quote
from Renewal by Anderson Renewal by
Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible supported
by the best people in the industry right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for 0 down zero payments and
zero interest for one year text nolles
kwes to 200 300 for your free
consultation and save $375 off every
window and $750 off every door these
savings will not last long so be sure to
check it out text Noles kwes to 200 300
I have gotten unsolicited emails there
was a carpenter who wrote to me and said
Michael I heard you do a read for
Renewal by Anderson whenever I work on a
home with Windows by Renewal by Anderson
it's just superior quality text Nolls to
200 300 texting privacy policy in terms
of conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages messag and dat
May apply reply stop to out go to window
appointment now.com for full offer
details lady Ballers the most triggering
comedy of the year is still one of the
most streamed movies in America it has
been a massive success and we could not
have done it without the support of all
our members now with over 5,000 raving
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes it has earned
a 91% audience score comedy has been
absolutely dead in the past 10 years it
is as though Hollywood forgot how to
make jokes or be funny but the daily
wire has resurrected comedy with Lady
Ballers we've also dropped the official
lady Ballers soundtrack available now on
Spotify Apple music Pandora and wherever
you stream music if you are not a daily
wire plusus member plans start at $14.99
a month you will get access to Lady
Ballers and all the rest of daily wire
pluses exclusive member content do not
wait sign up today at dailywire.com
subscribe speaking speaking
of the FBI and DC investigating things
an FBI agent was just uh
carjacked an FBI agent was carjacked in
Washington DC according to authorities
this is another high-profile incident in
DC in which a rampant crime has affected
not only the ordinary citizens but also
Federal officials and their families you
remember a few weeks ago the president's
granddaughter uh was carjacked and
Secret Service was with her and they
actually ended up firing on the suspect
and he still got away and now you've got
an FBI agent there there's some good
news here the good
news that comes out of stories like this
is that contrary to what many
conservatives fear the liberal
establishment is not
omnipotent far from it they're not
they're not there they can't just
exercise total power over you they don't
there aren't five people who secretly
control the entire World they they can't
even stop their own Agents from getting
carjacked they can't even stop the
president's granddaughter from getting
carjacked okay and they can't even shoot
the guy when he when he starts to do it
they're not
omnipotent that's the that's the good
side the bad side of this is things are
spiraling out of control the bad side to
this is they can't even stop their own
guys from getting
carjacked which means that chaos is
going
to abound and chaos abounding is not
good for anyone that is very bad news
it's true that'll harm our opponents and
enemies but it's going to harm us too
and things consp spiral out of control
very very quickly as our Elites are
seeing which is why some Democrats
actually are beginning to to change
their
rhetoric you want to talk about
nationalism John
fedman who is the Pennsylvania senator
who doesn't want to wear a suit and he
suffered a stroke and he's had all sorts
of brain problems and went into rehab or
some kind of Rehabilitation facility to
try to work on his uh cognitive
abilities well John fedman is a lot
smarter than he might seem because John
fedman has just come out and said quote
I hope Democrats can understand that it
isn't xenophobic to be concerned about
the Border this is what he told Politico
it is a reasonable conversation
democrats should engage this is the same
John fedman
who hired George Santos through Cameo
which is an app that allows you to get
famous people or slightly famous people
to give you personalized messages for
hundreds of dollars so now disgraced and
exiled Republican Congressman George
Santos made this Cameo video presumably
secretly for John fedman and the video
was attacking fetterman's Senate
colleague Democrat Bob Menendez hey
Bobby uh look I don't think I need to
tell you but these people that want to
make you get in trouble trouble and want
to kick you out and make you run away
you make him put up or shut up you stand
your ground sir and don't get bogged
down by all the haters out there stay
strong Merry Christmas hilarious really
really great I'm sure Santos had no idea
what he was doing here Federman or or
whoever is running feder's
Communications really brilliant troll of
mandez but it makes you ask why is John
fedman turning on his Senate colleague
Bob Mendez another the Democrat to me
it's simple enough the reason the
Democrats want Mendez out is because
every day that that guy remains in
office it becames hard harder and harder
for the Democrat who will replace him to
actually win the the corruption is going
to be exposed for so much longer to the
voters that it's going to harm all the
Democrats maybe even threaten their
majority so it's it's not that the
Democrats here have suddenly found
Integrity it's that they realize it's
hurting their own political interest to
let this guy stay in
office Menendez doesn't want to go
anywhere so John fedman comes out and he
starts trolling him really really hard
harder than any Democrat in the Senate
he's made other statements too and then
to come out and say hey border security
should not be a partisan issue we should
all want border
security what fedman realizes is
something that the Democrats broadly
have forgotten which is that the loss of
workingclass
credibility is
absolutely devastating it is deadly to
the Democrat political project
devastating and Federman knows this
because Pennsylvania is a Rust Belt
State and so the Democrats there tend to
be a little bit more Blue Collar than
they are in California or New York
fetman saying out of his own political
interest I'm sure hey if we truly become
the party of limousine riding latte
sipping private jet taking climate
change John Cary yacht goinging frr Libs
then we're going to lose or not we're
not I'm going to lose in
Pennsylvania so he comes out and he
starts to adopt these more basic meat
and potatoes kind of issues pretty smart
but luckily for us Federman seems to be
the only Democrat who's getting the
message at least on the border issue a
lot of Democrats are getting the message
when it comes to Joe Biden's
unpopularity including the fill-in host
for the Daily Show Daily Show founded by
Craig kilborn and many of you are not
old enough to remember that then becomes
very popular at least among uh DC
journalists and you know makes a big
splash under John Stewart then it's
taken over by Trevor Noah who has never
said a funny thing ever once in his life
and they let him keep that show for a
while eventually he leaves now it's just
been a cycle of Fillin hosts this guy is
Charlemagne the God is is his uh stage
name and he's a radio host we've played
clips of him before he's he's pretty
funny he's obviously a big
lib here is Charlemagne the gods take on
President Biden so Donald Trump is
currently running on a platform of
dictatorship and the only man standing
in his way is President Joe Biden seeing
here looking at his own approval
ratings I know he thinks he's got this
in the bag but the polls say otherwise I
want Biden stepping in to beat Trump the
way I want him stepping in to defend me
at a bar
fight I appreciate you Karen but I don't
like our
chances the point is we don't need Biden
to beat Donald Trump just like we didn't
need RBG to stay on the court okay maybe
if RBG had retired during the Obama
years we'd still have Ro v Wade maybe
but people said no she needs to be here
to protect Ro and now look both of them
are
gone it's true they're both
going see the facts are Biden's not
getting any younger he's not going to
get any more popular and he's not
getting a new running mate so please Mr
President give America The Ultimate
Christmas gift and step aside
you know this is not the funniest
monologue I've ever seen But compared to
years of Trevor
Noah this guy is Norm McDonald Bob Hope
and Rodney Dangerfield all rolled up
into one you know this guy is really
really much funnier than Trevor Noah and
his point is much
better yeah Joe Biden is a major
liability for the Democrats I agree
Donald Trump could conceivably beat Joe
Biden if the libs don't rip it I totally
agree maybe even if the libs do rig it
is just Biden's approval ratings are so
low and Trump seems to be doing pretty
well head
to-head all that said though I bet that
Biden is still the nominee I'm not sure
about that I know there are a lot of
Democrats and Republicans who were
saying no he's at the last minute he's
going to step aside nah he's not he
can't run again he's too old he's too
scile it's not going to happen I'm not
betting the farm but I would bet a small
amount of money Joe Biden will be the
Democrat nominee for president barring
some you know major health incident I
just don't think this guy is going to
step aside voluntarily I think Joe Biden
has wanted to be the president since he
was in the womb I think it would be
embarrassing to leave after one term it
would be a sign of failure and I don't
think he wants to do it and he doesn't
like kamla Harris he hates her Kamala
Harris launched her campaign calling Joe
Biden a racist Joe Biden has no love for
kamla Harris he is not going to do it
for Pete Budaj give me a break the the
silly mayor of South Bend uh uhuh you
know you don't get to go on maternity
leave when you're the president of the
United States he's not doing that he's
not maybe Gavin Newsome he's the most in
the Biden mold but I don't think Biden
cares about anybody really I think Biden
cares about
Biden and
furthermore even from the perspective of
the democratic
party it just looks bad to lose your
nominee e even if Biden is polling in in
pretty bad numbers right
now it's a sign of weakness this is why
you always hear this uh when when a
president is running for re-election
they say will he change his running mate
oh that running mate's not that popular
KLA Harris is first of all presidents
often benefit if they have a slightly
weak running mate because it's an
argument against impeachment or
assassination but
two if you change things up you are
admitting that you have failed and right
now the Democrats are still straight
face saying Biden he's achieved so much
so much oh things have never been better
a gallon of milk costs $300 now but
things have never we've got World War
III breaking out in Eastern Europe and
in the Middle East but no things are
just thank goodness it's not like it was
under Trump when the economy great was
great and we had World Peace yeah no
thank goodness now everything's broken
but they're straight facing it and if
they're going to straight face it then
they got to keep the nominee to lose the
nominee is to admit that the guy failed
that he was too old he was too weak too
incompetent never underestimate Joe's
ability to F things up to quote the
former Democrat president so my money a
modest amount of money he's still the
nominee now speaking of the presidential
nominees a poll has just come out from
three groups you know they always say
it's like the
ABC Harvard Pole or whatever well this
is the 538 Washington Post ipsos poll so
goodness gracious that's three groups
and they say that Ronda santis won the
fourth Republican debate and I basically
agree with that he won in the sense that
he was the most steady the most
presidential sure okay I I think that
the debate was the best debate by far I
think Megan Kelly by far was the best
moderator we've seen at any of these
debates really at any debate in recent
years but so what so what Ronda santis
won the debate cool how are the poll
numbers moving uh not at
all
why sometimes winning a debate
helps the problem is these debates were
not actually presidential debates
because the guy who's leading the pack
by 40 or 50 points even didn't show up
so it was a fun little exercise it was a
simulacrum of a presidential debate it
was a distant faint echo of a pres but
it even if you hate Trump and you like
DeSantis or V or Haley or Chris Christie
if you're were the one guy out there me
who just loves the chry assant and is
waiting for the croissant to just
totally take then
even still I think you have to admit it
just doesn't matter that and a buck 50
will get you a cup of coffee here's some
further proof of that you don't even
need to just look at the polls the
political powers that be on the
conservative side especially actually on
the establishment and more Centra side
the fence sitting side they're they they
hate Donald Trump in the establishment
they hate his guts they' tried to
destroy him for 78 years but but the
establishment Will Survive okay the EST
they are like cockroaches they will will
they will not go quietly they will not
go down for Valor or Integrity they will
survive and they are seeing the writing
on the wall so the political
establishment at least this slightly
more conservative part of the political
establishment uh McCarthy former Speaker
of the House slightly more conservative
than the previous speakers of the house
than the previous uh slimy establishment
in DC McCarthy just endorsed Trump well
Donald Trump be the nominee yes and the
Republican party yes and if Biden stays
as the nominee for the
Democrats I believe Donald Trump will
win I believe the Republicans will gain
more seats in the house and the
Republicans will win the Senate can he
count on your support yes that's an
endorsement I will support the president
I will support president Trump would you
be willing to serve in a trump cabinet
in the right position look if if I'm the
best person for the job yes look I've
worked with President Trump on a lot of
policies I we work together to win the
majority but we also have a relationship
where we're very honest with one
another this is the GOP establishment
coming to terms with reality Now Kevin
McCarthy has supported Trump in the past
and Trump has supported McCarthy in the
past and I've said it before this is
always my caveat I know McCarthy's very
unpopular Now by establishment standards
he's about as good as they get damning
with Fain praise perhaps but
still McCarthy endorsing here so openly
is a sign of the establishment coming to
grips with reality and there's an even
clearer sign of that and it's coming
from the GOP Presidential field first
though I got to tell you about my
friends over at the St Paul center right
now go to St Paul center.com I recently
had my friend Dr Scott Han on the show
he is the founder of the St Paul Center
which is one of the fastest growing
Catholic organizations in the world the
St Paul Center's mission is to give you
the tools you need to know to love
scripture better to become more
confident in your faith and most
importantly to grow closer to Christ
himself in order to achieve this the St
Paul Center founded a new digital
learning platform called EMAs Academy
Mayas Academy features over 20 video
courses book studies and original series
giving you the ability to learn from
worldclass theologians such as Dr Scott
Han and Dr John Burma as if you were
right there with them in the classroom I
absolutely love their video studies I
love everything that they put out their
12 session study by Dr Han is incredible
he traced is the meaning of Holiness
from its origins in scripture to its
appearance in our own lives today this
study will help you experience the
transformative power of God's holiness
start learning more about church history
how to interpret the Bible the basics of
Christian prayer and more good to stpaul
center.com and you can begin exploring
EMAs Academy memberships are only 25
bucks per month but you can sign up
today for a two-e free trial imagine
what could be possible if we were all to
fortify ourselves with a deeper
understanding of scripture and Faith do
not not miss this opportunity to sign up
today to begin your journey with Emmas
Academy my favorite comment on Friday is
from Jacob lhan who says I fell for the
2006 Time person of the year joke what
joke it's one of my most cherished
awards that I've ever gotten put it
right on my
CV there's even clearer evidence that
the establishment is coming to terms
with the likelihood that Trump is the
JPY nominee that's from within the
presidential field
it's Nikki Haley asked if Trump is fit
to be president now someone who thinks
that he or she is on the brink of
destroying Trump as a candidate taking
that nomination away from him the answer
would be no no way that's get out of
here that guy's a total joker I'm the
one who's fit here is Nikki's answer
Ambassador certainly a big surge in the
polls lately want to start where the
last debate left off uh where one
question went unanswered as far as is
Donald Trump Trump fit to be president
Chris Christie said he's unfit I want to
just put that directly to you in a yes
or no it's not about Fitness I think
he's fit to be president it should he be
president I don't think he should be
president you know I thought he was the
right president at the right time I
agreed with a lot of his policies the
problem is you see our country is in
disarray our world is on fire and you
can't defeat Democrat chaos with the
Republican chaos and Donald Trump brings
us chaos
it's a good answer from Nikki Haley
Nikki is a very talented
politician that's a hedge is what that
is in part Nikki has to give this sort
of an answer because she worked for
Trump she was Trump's very public very
prominent un
[Music]
Ambassador she previously said she
wouldn't run for president if Trump ran
again then she ran for president but
what she said was yeah I just don't
think he's the right guy at this
time then is much harsher on Trump and
now you're seeing back you of course
he's
fit I just don't think he's the ideal
candidate right now that is a
hedge people like to make fun of
politicians on the debate stages the
ones that don't seem to be doing very
well if you make it to a presidential
debate stage I don't care if you're Doug
berham okay I don't care if you're ASA
Hutchinson if you make it there you're a
pretty good politician if you manage to
get yourself elected governor of your
state
there's a good chance you're a pretty
good politician if you manage to make it
to the United States Senate you're a
pretty good politician okay and good
politicians know how to survive and what
you are seeing here and what you're
probably going to start seeing from the
rest of the not only GOP field but even
the the just the political establishment
more broadly is people are going to
start speaking in much more glowing
terms about Donald Trump
even people who have previously attacked
him even people who have endorsed
Trump's primary opponents and and issued
invective after invective against Trump
and the reason for that is no strategy
thus far has seemed able to take him
down DeSantis is the best governor in
America he's the best governor in my
lifetime nothing he's done has worked
that's why now you're seeing the big big
establishment money start to switch over
to Nikki Haley that's why you're seeing
these these uh moderators and these
interviewers say oh you're surging in
the polls what does surging in the polls
mean when when the leader in the party
is at 53 54% you're at 10% or 12% that's
not I guess it's surging from eight or
9% but it's just the Gap is just too big
the Head Start is just too big the Trump
had because he's been running for
president for four years now he's been
running for president for seven years
now so what are you going to do if
you're one of these guys even if you
were the biggest anti-trumper you are
going to start tempering your
attacks now I will happily support
whoever can beat Joe Biden I'm not one
of these people who says I'll only vote
for Trump or I'll only vote for Dan
santis or I'll only only vote for Nikki
Haley or something I would happily vote
for anyone who could beat Joe Biden not
because I think all the candidates are
perfect I certainly don't but because I
think Joe Biden is just that bad there
is a rule that has been proposed by the
Biden
Administration to discriminate against
Christian couples in adopting children
that would effectively bar practicing
Christians from adopting children
Nationwide this is Biden's HHS Health
and Human Services
Department requiring that Foster or
adoptive parents support a
[Music]
child's
liberalism often and increasingly
expresses itself as is a totalitarian
system and if you're if you consider
yourself a liberal Christian or a
liberal Jew or a liberal Muslim I don't
know many liberal Muslims but there are
some actually or
a or a liberal normal
person you're going to have to choose
those views are going to come into
conflict and only one of them will win
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member
use code NOS canw has a checkout for two
months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
a